what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and well it looks
like mine and everybody else's theory of
reed richard
showing up and the finale of one
division has unfortunately
been debunked as the director of the
show is opened up about what to expect
and specifically what
not to expect from the finale of one of
vision episode 9 that is just a couple
of days away
and some good news right off the bat it
does seem like
marvel is going to address evan peters's
quicksilver whether or not he
is from the main marvel cinematic
universe and agatha just picked a random
civilian
or if he's actually from the fox
universe and the multiverse is
happening which is going to be great to
finally have an answer to and i'll talk
about that later on in this video
it's been a lot of fun dissecting easter
eggs and trying to figure out what
exactly was happening
in westview this entire time but come
friday morning it's all going to be
revealed and we're all going to be
a little bit sad that one division is
over so quickly
but we still have the finale and there's
still a lot to go down
so let's break down what director matt
shakman had to say about the finale
what he had to say about our fan
theories and what to expect
and what not to expect from wanda vision
episode 9
the finale if you're new and you love
marvel be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest mcu videos
so the director of the one division
series matt shakman has recently opened
up to some
media outlets where he talked about the
finale of one division that is coming up
and specifically he talked about some of
the fan theories that some of us have
created
and although he didn't talk about all of
them there are some big ones that he did
discredit
however he also does go on to give us
hope about the finale as well
so let's first start off with what we
can not expect to happen during the one
division finale and then we'll dive into
what we can expect to happen during the
finale
now i think a lot of us by now have
realized that some of the theories out
there aren't going to happen
sadly but let's keep it focused on wanda
and her story like director matt
shachman would have us do he starts off
in one interview talking about how he
hopes fans are not disappointed by the
finale
during his interview with indiewire he
said i hope they feel like the journey
was satisfying for them
i know there are so many theories out
there there will be a lot of people who
will no doubt be disappointed by one
theory or another
but we're always telling the story about
wanda dealing with grief and learning
how to accept that loss
and hopefully people will find that the
finale is surprising but also
satisfying and that it feels inevitable
because it's the same story they've been
watching the whole time
so it's very clear that director matt
shackman has heard a lot of the theories
that we've put out there but don't get
discouraged by what he says because he
says that he hopes fans aren't
disappointed because there are so many
theories out there
mephisto nightmare cathone reed richards
heck yesterday i did a video that had
about five different theories in it so
the point that he's making
is that there are a ton of theories out
there he hopes fans aren't disappointed
by all of those theories not happening
that's not to say that some of the
theories may not happen it's to say that
all of them aren't going to happen so we
shouldn't expect that then in an
interview with comicbook.com he
specifically talked about the reed
richards aerospace engineer theory
in the interview he said that he's sorry
for the single tear down every fan's
cheek about the aerospace engineer
in this interview he basically confirmed
that we have already in fact met the
aerospace engineer this was most likely
agent goodner who greeted monica and
jimmy wu a lot of us thought
and hoped that this wasn't actually the
aerospace engineer and that they would
actually reveal the aerospace engineer
down the line
but it appears that we were wrong as
director matt shakman says i'm sorry
and he also says i mean sure it would
have been great if reed richards had
showed up in that room
that would have been pretty great so it
looks like the aerospace engineer is not
going to be reed richards but was in
fact all along
major goodner but as i said yesterday
there's no certainty that this
is the cameo that paul bettany was
talking about now we don't know if he
was talking about himself but there is
still hope for a surprise cameo which
matt shackman kind of talks about later
on
but let's talk about what we can expect
and as i mentioned he did address the
quicksilver multiverse question
shakman explained that the idea came
fairly early in the development of the
show
this question of who would be at the
door and grief does a lot to a person
in terms of what they're willing to
accept speaking of course of evan
peters's quicksilver and then he says
and yes agatha lets you know that she
was pulling the strings on that
trying to get a little more information
and then when directly asked if evan
peters was portraying the same character
he played in another film's franchise
movie
aka the fox x-men universe he was asked
if this was an intentional
multiverse thread or if this was simply
a coincidence it seems like there's a
big surprise coming for the finale
because his response was
we'll have to meet again some monday in
the future to talk about it
meaning that he can't talk about it
right now because it's going to be
revealed in the episode finale on
friday so one thing that we can expect
the finale to give us
is the backstory of who evan peters
character
actually is and is this the first sign
of the multiverse
in the same interview he also confirms
that we aren't going to get a
major cliffhanger he said that they're
going to wrap up the story of what has
been happening in
west view and he says that he hopes that
there's some resolution to that story
and that it is satisfying and also
surprising to the fans
and again he used the word surprising so
there is going to be some big surprise
during the finale possibly doctor
strange because he does say that this
story is going to continue in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
and he does say
that there's a lot more to her story
wanda to be told
and he says this is only one part of a
very complicated and very rich
life now the way he talks about this
makes it seem like this might be the end
for agatha harkness although i hope not
because that could be a very big waste
of
a character but perhaps agatha's story
won't continue in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness but pick up
somewhere later on in the mcu
but what he did say about the story is
that it's not going to pivot it's not
going to do
a 180 at the last minute he says they've
known the story that they wanted to tell
from the beginning and it's been
building towards a final moment that
made sense from the very beginning
he says hopefully it feels that it's
been building momentum and snowballing
towards the end
it is continuing to deal with how do you
deal with grief and loss and come back
from that
and then we've introduced some new
players on the table as well
or revealed aspects of certain players
on the table so you now have
two visions on the chessboard and what
does that mean who's the real
vision this is something that we all
expected obviously the two visions are
going to go at it and who's going to
come out on top
and are either one of them going to
remain alive after the end
in multiple interviews director matt
shackman has said that wanda vision is a
story of
wanda's loss so does this mean that
neither vision is going to survive or
maybe her children aren't going to
survive either he finishes by saying
she's lost her parents she's lost her
brother she's lost the love of her life
by now and she's right on the edge like
how do you hold together your reality
when you're constantly experiencing so
much trauma
so again the story is about loss and
trauma so what happens if
wanda loses her entire family that she
made in her perfect reality
if you combine this with the fact that
he said this is only part one of wanda's
long
very rich and complicated story we can
expect that there
is indeed going to be more loss that
puts her over the edge which of course
will threaten the reality because she
has chaos magic
reality warping magic but that's where
doctor strange comes in
he can teach her to control this magic
and based off of what the director said
i think it's safe to assume that doctor
strange is going to show up whether it's
in the actual finale or in the
post-credit scene of the finale
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios already said that this first
season
of one division is season one and doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness is
kind of like season two of wanda vision
and elizabeth olsen is already filming
for multiverse of madness as we speak
so this is going to go right into it but
we haven't heard anything about paul
bettany being in multiverse of madness
or
either of the twins so it looks like
more loss is going to be coming to wanda
but she'll have doctor strange to help
her and guide her in multiverse of
madness
but what are your final predictions for
what's going to happen
in one division episode 9 the finale let
me know what you think in the comments
down below
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest marvel
videos
don't forget to give the video a like
and for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
hmm